forevermore september 15th will be
roberto clemente day in major league
baseball there he is your
2021 roberto clemente award winner for
the braves one will
smith moscar's had some tough luck since
he's came back from the il hasn't had
much luck on the win loss column but his
stuff's been pretty good teams are
hitting a buck 61 against him here at
truest park he struck him out with a
high heat hamson chased ball four good
start for noah one out
yeah it'll be interesting to see what
kind of grip he can get on the ball
noticed he got a break there by hampson
climbing the ladder and swinging at it
but
the last four pitches we've seen from
you noah chip all missed up the infield
looks to be in good shape
wet baseball for dansby and a perfect
throw and two quick outs and he just
struck out charlie blackmon and retires
the rockies in order with a couple of
strikeouts sensatella is on the mound
and for antonio it'll be start number
25. forget the record
i don't know if anybody is pitching
better over the last couple of months in
the rockies rotation then this man
and he's gonna have himself a base hit
there
so he got a slider and he lines it to
center field so alfie's aboard with his
speed and that'll bring up jorge solaire
and uh this is a comebacker sensatella
that's great feed on first or lair into
a convenient one four three double play
and that's line to left and hilliard got
a good break on the baseball and
takes extra bases away from freddie
freeman riley duvall and darno for the
braves here in the bottom of the second
inning
line in a right center field that ball
was smoked by riley
that's the second leadoff hit for
atlanta good spot strike three on the
outside corner
that's strike three then darno just
walked away he got fooled dansby with
two outs
shot to right field good approach for
swanson
riley on his way to second and he will
stand there here comes rosario with two
on and two out well it's a special day
in major league baseball a man wearing a
special number is coming up let's see
what rosario can do
as this one is cracked toward the gap in
right center get out ball there's a base
head a run is in
first and third for atlanta rosario
ambushes a first pitch in atlanta
strikes first in the second a big two
out here yeah you're going to honor
roberto clemente why not do that and
drive him the first run tonight
swung out of miss that'll end the inning
there were three singles in the inning
to produce a run for atlanta so as we go
to the third the braves up at home one
nothing on colorado
in the braves third inning brings up
jorge solaire looking to extend that
career-best 11-game hitting streak he's
hitting everything right now and he
continues that
with a shot the other way with one out
so solaire with a 12-game hitting streak
that matches dansby swanson's 12-game
hitting streak for the longest by any
brave this year
and this is on the ground to crow
there's one return throw and plenty of
time three six three double play
second turn behind senzatella for sam
hilliard who struck out his first time
and the other way a base hit for
hilliard and the rockies have the
leadoff man out for the third time in
five innings
and a base hit the other way for welker
so colt throws out his fourth big league
hit now the rockies
have two on and no one out
now dom lifts this ball to center field
tagging at seconds hilliard and
he is going to move up
so now
in a one-nothing game senzutella first
and third
and that is gloves and a high throw from
freddy freeman
it kicks right back to darneau
everyone's safe 1-1 ball game
and maybe again the moisture on the
baseball affected freeman i don't know
even if he's on target
with this baseball if he's going to get
hillary i think it surprised him a
little bit sam speed because when he
caught it he almost acted surprised like
oh i've got to go home watch this
there's a slight hesitation
and he knew it immediately when he threw
it 3-2 missed badly inside and they are
loaded for brendan rodgers the o2
he struck him out
three disappearing sliders jeff and he
looks like a man refreshed two out bases
full two outs one one game that'll bring
up blackman
good take so charlie who swung at those
sliders the first two times up spit on
that one and he puts the rockies in
front
with a sexy walk he'll take it 75 rbis
now for chuck nasty and jacob webb will
face trevor story he struck him out what
a sequence for jacob webb and boy did
the braves need that first man do is
eddie rosario swag in a drive hit high
in the air deep right field eddie
rosario with a bomb on an 02 pitch
i'd say that's beating the pressure and
mother nature 2-2 game and doing your
best roberto clemente honoring him
wearing 21.
single on an rbi in the second
and now ties the game up in the fifth
one away in top of the order
it's great play by crone
and off to senzatella well done by cj
yeah and a normal night when the ground
is dry everything's dry that this is a
great play but it's even more remarkable
when we were just talking about that
glassy look
and what's happening right in front of
cj and
you know he's diving and sliding around
in the mud over there and the muck
comes up and makes a strong field for
antonio brown
continues its work before the top of the
seventh inning i i would think
this is the last ditch effort here i
think ed just brought his trump card out
this is the ace for him
high fly ball center duvall retreats
he's gonna have room and metzik
continues his marvelous work two on one
out jack peterson's gonna swing the bat
for the braves and he will face
left-hander lucas gilbreth as this one's
lifted to the left side into the rain
who wants it hilliard comes on and makes
the catch
and peterson pops out for the second out
pitch is inside they're loaded for
solaire
bases loaded two out
popped up
krone back pedals
and is called off and staggering and
making the catches rogers and that will
retire the side the braves got three
walks
but could not break the deadlock
31-year-old will smith is on for atlanta
cj crone again will lead it off for the
rockies
and a little dribbler
that is on the line smith's got it fires
to first and they got him wow what a
play
smith grabbed it slipped as he made the
throw and that one looked like it hurt
freeman's
glove hand
oh he stepped on him right above the
left thumb
totally accidental
and how about freeman hanging in there
as krone spikes him the pitch
swing and a miss that got away from
darnold for a moment and freeman handles
it first and the braves perfect run and
relief has continued and it will be
estevez on to
try to force a 10th inning
swung on and missed and estevez comes
back
and strikes out the dangerous eddie
rosario
that ball of bullet to center field
second hit of the night
for albies the speed at first the
winning run at first
that's low you're gonna get freeman with
the winning run at second
and this ball has hit a ton to center
field hampson will get there
and we're going to extra innings
bob nunez
will lead it off
and this ball is pulled to second so
nunez gets the ball to play to the right
side
and he moves welker to third so one out
with welker at third in a 2-2 game in
the 10th and here's rymel tapia and that
is through the middle for a base hit
wilker scores to give the rockies a 3-2
lead and rymel toppy on the first pitch
delivers
they got him picked off if freddy can
make a good throw he couldn't but ozzy
scooped it up now it's a rundown
tapia
is finally gonna be tagged down as he
lost his footing
swinging a drive hammered toward left
and rosario is there to retire the side
rockies leading the braves in the bottom
of the tent three to two
robert stephenson will try to keep
atlanta off the board one two swung on
and missed one out huge
got him upstairs with a fastball to
strike out darno for the second out
this is popped up and playable shallow
right charlie the atlanta native has it
and the rockies win three to two at 10.
you